government official says most of the
eligible young immigrant children who
were separated at the border should be
back with their parents by this morning
federal judge said yesterday that's
seventy five over the hundred and two
children under the age of five were
eligible for reunification but 12 of
those 75 eligible children's families
have already been deported and their
location is unknown nearly 3,000
children between the ages of 5 and 17
remain separated from their parents
Matea Villarreal is in El Paso Texas
following the complicated reunification
process by day a good morning well good
morning right now Judge Dana Sabra is
expecting another update from the
federal government on the progress of
reunifying those families that end up at
shelters like this one here in El Paso
we were there for one of those emotional
reunifications that happened late last
night Bernardino considered a stray who
and his daughter Fernanda arrived in
Baltimore two familiar faces after a
long and risky journey Bernardino says
he and Fernanda were separated for 27
days he claims they came to the u.s.
seeking asylum after fleeing violence in
their native Honduras we wrote along
with them earlier in the day on the way
to the airport but nothing here
he says officials were telling him at
the border at the bridge like here you
mean nothing like you don't you don't
have any rights here like we're gonna
take your daughter away did you know
that it was possible you know something
he didn't know that it was possible they
could separate Bernardino and Fernando
were reunited at a nice detention
facility late Tuesday evening then
brought to the annunciation house
shelter in El Paso he was one of three
fathers reunited with children there
Fernanda is one of at least 38 children
under five who have reconnected with
families in recent days after a judge's
a 14 day deadline expired Bernardino
doesn't know where fare nanda was held
but she remembers the frightening
experience
he said that they
treated her bad and scolded her how do
you hear that input into how Earl assess
what he remains positive there are a lot
of people that are going to want to
deport you he says send you back to your
country keep reminding yourself while
you're here and this is about the
children and keeping them safe right now
the family is planning to stay in
Maryland to work on their Asylum case
now all three of the father's that were
reunited here in El Paso did not do any
of the DNA testing and also they were
not given ankle bracelets our sources
are saying right now the government is
looking to scale back on some of those
stricter requirements to speed up the
reunification process John Gray on this
story for us thank you Maria